Judy's with us in Buffalo New York hi
Judy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you
I have a question Dave will be tired so
we live on a fixed income I have two
debts two major debts one is a $15,000
home equity line of credit that's left
over from my kids college and a 5,000
about $5,000 in credit card debt and how
much is your first mortgage payment
nothing we is the only debt you have in
all the world except for car car payment
oh how much do you owe on your car well
yeah we're do we sing it how much is
your payment $199 a month okay and what
is your monthly income well about $3,000
and how much money do you have in your
nest egg I have $6,000 saved to your
name yes you don't have any money so for
retirement just no just the only thing
we have is our Social Security and I
have a real small pension $400 you don't
have anything saved for retirement no
and how old are you 69 okay all right
yeah you got a problem don't you yeah
well my question I've been plugging away
at these two debts you know and what my
question is if I keep hearing this
snowball thing when I listen to your
show and what I'm wondering is should I
stop paying extra on the home equity
line of credit and just pay the interest
and pay it all on the credit card yes
yes yes I stay current on the home
equity loan minimum payment you can pay
without getting behind and then pay
everything on the credit card until it's
gone have you cut the credit card up
yeah yeah I don't I uh I don't use it I
bought it oh yes okay yes fine
not sure it sounds like you're gonna do
that when you get off the phone to me
okay but yeah you need to cut it up and
be done with it
right and then the other thing we got a
wreck because what you got to recognize
is you have no wiggle room right and so
you can't be doing things with payments
ever again Karlie's equals bad idea
well my other car just yeah we couldn't
use it anymore you could too
it was it's a frame broke on it and you
can pay $199 a month you can put $199 a
month in a cookie jar for 10 months and
buy a $2,000 car okay that's what you
got to do you got to do like your
grandma did save up and pay for it or
don't buy it because here's the thing
you guys don't have any wiggle room by
the time you eat and pay lights and and
so forth you know I'm pay your taxes and
your insurance on the house so you don't
lose it right when all these other debts
are just they're just they're kicking
your teeth in I mean your car payment is
$199 and that's out of a $3,000
existence and you have absolutely no
money to go to other than that little
six thousand dollar emergency fund so I
just gotta beg you to stay out and away
from debt no matter what happens don't
care how big the emergency is you can't
go back in there so cut up the credit
card now that we're off the phone and
you may want to think about getting out
of this car and see if you can get it
sold and get it get out of this lease
because it's a problem and then let's
get your house paid off so that because
if you had no car payment no credit card
debt and no HELOC you sure have a lot
more room in that three thousand bucks
that's that's where I want you to be
because you've got a real tight
existence here ouch
you